should that just be part of the movie
now he loves
his string there was a time in disney
and pixar's history where they didn't
take themselves so seriously it was
brief but we loved it all the same it's
time the animated bloopers made a
comeback don't you agree until they do
let's take a trip down memory lane
hey
[Laughter]
okay very funny number one we're
starting with a memory pixar would
rather have us forget
the casting couch blooper was deleted
from any product disney still sells and
so you two are absolutely identical this
happened following the metoo movement
you know i'm sure i could get you a part
in toy story 3. thank gosh for the
internet never letting you forget
anything anytime you'd like some tips on
acting i'd be glad to chat with you this
blooper is pretty tasteless but accurate
nonetheless number two is anybody taping
this
a little healthier place woody got
himself in quite the
sticky situation
number three what's all the buzz about
oh it's just woody up to his antics
again we wouldn't have taken woody for
the type to be a prankster we'll be back
before andy gets home
what what are you laughing about
honestly we would have expected that
behavior from ham
maybe and action
[Music]
but you can't convince us buzz can't see
the circles on his helmet what what's so
funny
woody
number four useless junk is a necessity
for long trips i'm packing you an extra
pair of shoes and your angry eyes how
much junk can you fit in that trunk mrs
potato head and if you get hungry here's
some cheese puffs can mr potato head
even eat if mrs potato head is packing
food inside of mr potato head is that
technically considered eaten and some
extra tea be careful they chatter
the trunk would be more like a kangaroo
pouch we think and a rubber ducky
and a yo-yo we don't leave home without
our rubber ducky and some blue play-doh
listen gas is bound to happen it's just
human nature was that me
oh my but wait these are toys
i don't remember eating that
i can't believe it's coming from the
bean burrito does buzz have a
compartment for food like potato head
number six oh how the future could have
been so different right now imagine if
instead of sentient toys we got bugs
bugs and more bugs you know i can't
believe that you talked them into making
a bug's life too well a bug's life
sequel would be awesome i don't
understand what is it then
toy story 2 was the right direction to
take number seven boy does pixar ever
love their cameos hey ted good morning
we thought this leg looked familiar they
gave that part to rex right hey how was
that was i scary do i get the part but
wait if toy rex is that big then how
small is sully how small is mike how
small does that make boo
number eight raw's the tender oozing
blossom pops up quite like flowers in
springtime
we couldn't remember exactly why we
loved roz but this is it
do you think she came in on her day off
to surprise sully what a gem it's empty
see guess who number nine chemistry is
so important go get them mr solomon
smitty and needleman are as goofy behind
the scenes as they are in the movie no
idiot it's
what sometimes we love a perfect casting
you're never gonna work in hollywood
again maybe not so perfect casting keep
rolling you're making it work number ten
the scare floor is overrated the laugh
floor is overrated let's try the slip
floor
okay
somebody needs to tone it down with the
wax or something sheesh can we get a
little more wax on the floor please who
is the wax guy is that a designated job
is that what the gaffer does he needs a
serious talking too because this is just
unacceptable number eleven and now we've
come full circle back to toy
story to infinity and beyond
you've gone so beyond that you're
quoting the wrong movie
i'm sorry i couldn't resist number 12
it's got to be so hard playing a villain
when your co-stars don't take you
seriously do i look
stupid to you
guess you got your answer hopper are you
saying i'm stupid
with every take it digs a little deeper
i cannot work like this i will be in my
trailer and when he came back instead of
cracking skulls he was still cracking up
his co-stars
number 13 we bet this was the first time
film equipment had ever even been
animated in cgi before the idea for the
animated bloopers came during the first
toy story actually it wasn't even my
idea
i'm sorry i'm sorry is the camera broke
unfortunately it was so late into
production that they didn't get the
chance to add them so a bug's life
became the first animated movie with
bloopers we admire the speed the boom
ops drop their boom when the shots are
wrecked to give their arms a break
that's why we are petitioning to have
them retitled the boom op portunists
honestly though we'd be taking every
opportunity for a break too number 14
and speaking of breaks
malfunctions can often lead to one oh
does this mean we can break for lunch
number 15. we're shook pixar included
this so is there a mrs ant do you have
to panel home to
what do you plan on doing with that
cardboard bug doctor flora oh dear put
that thing in my car number 16. they
were using real berries the whole time
here we thought it was prosthetics oh my
eye oh no no seriously i've got berry
juice in my eye the one thing that sucks
about being an actor is even if you
could physically work through the pain
they would pick up the redness on camera
oh stop the camera number seventeen what
makes the ants humanoid and whatever
aphey is a pet
oh towel i need a doll over here
you know what they say in showbiz don't
work with kids or pets while you're at
it just work alone life is better in
isolation number 18 we spotted another
cameo timon eats afie
tastes like chicken
[Music]
secretly timon didn't even like bugs
either i think i got a bad grub all
grubs are bad number 19 the king of the
jungles just going to need a minute or
so to get into character
mufasa should probably consult his vocal
coach there's a sound down in the throat
somewhere i just don't know how to reach
it we're pretty sure that's not how
not that either
[Music]
definitely not a roar
as close as i can get right now all that
for nothing number 20. nobody goes home
until we get this right
wow
no
wow
no come on director timon is giving you
acting gold here all he's asking for is
a little reassurance he's doing the
right thing do you want any of this
stuff i'm doing comedy is way harder
than drama and you know what's harder
than crying on screen laughing on screen
number 21 who wouldn't trust the wise
old baboon with their pride and joy
maybe everyone was better off when
rafiki was asleep
but the only thing worse than dropping
the future king of the jungle is
hey that's not simba
number 22 this one's a no-brainer
who would you choose aladdin or stitch
the one with the dusty old carpet or the
one with the shiny new ride hey did you
get your own movie we know what we would
pick number 23 ariel's true colors are
showing watch and you'll see
a little blue dude ruin your ballad
i was singing here
it's just plain rude of ariel to throw a
starfish at the fluffy little guy it's
not like stitch controls the weather
that's left to pudge the fish number 24
if somebody kissed stitch would he turn
into a prince we can blame stitch for
this one tail as old as time true as it
can be barely even friends then somebody
falls from the ceiling and ruins the
mood entirely causing the beast to live
in exile as a beast for the rest of
existence i'll be in my room
get your own movie number 25 the logo
that started it all pixar hasn't had a
whole lot of variation in their logo
over the years but they have made a few
special considerations like the one they
did for wally fun fact the lamp has a
name luxo jr and we've gathered that the
letter i is a stand-in for jumping on
the bed do you know what's more fun than
jumping on the bed folding the mattress
in half and launching yourself across
the room it works true story don't try
it at home though you will wreck your
mattress
animated bloopers are like pizza crust
everybody says they're the best part but
they're not but still good
yeah
still good you wouldn't go to a theater
just to see the bloopers would you now
that we've started that controversy let
us know what your favorite part of a
pizza planet slices in the comments and
thanks for hanging out with us here at
the things